hi there steve here it's day three of my
90 day korean challenge day three for me
some of you may have started earlier
um
today i want to focus on i'll talk a
little bit about what i've done today
i should remind you that i i get the
message about giving uh doing videos in
different languages we're going to do
them with english subtitles so it'll
take a while first to have to do them
then we have to translate them produces
subtitles but you'll be seeing those
hopefully within a week or so
and so the various requests for japanese
for spanish for portuguese chinese
cantonese any request i get if i can do
it i'm going to do it
today i want to talk about the process
talk a bit about what i'm doing
um
because very often you know um people
are involved in this in this process of
listening and reading
the occasional grammar review the
occasional conversation but the bulk of
the time at least in my case is
listening and reading
for example today
uh my numbers just today
i have added 205 known words
and i have saved 162 links that is i
have saved
162 words a few phrases at this point
to my database so there was a question
how do i know how many words i know
well at link
when you are reading on link
if you don't save a word
then the system assumes you know that
word otherwise you would have saved it
or if you've saved a word and it starts
out as a status one word and eventually
you get to know that word you can
manually move it to known or by doing
your flashcards or other activities it
can be moved to known
so
that's how we count them that's how i
know how many words i know
no meaning
understand in a context understand it so
well that i didn't bother saving it of
course if i come across the word again
and i now don't know what it means i can
save it again and the statistics adjust
so there are times when we're not
confident that we're making any progress
so today i basically worked on three
types of content i started out with my
podcasts which are very difficult which
i've had transcribed they're full of
words that i don't know
even if i read through and save all the
words and kind of half know what it
means when i hear the podcast i have a
lot of trouble i don't really understand
it
so then i did that for a while and it's
often going to start with a difficult
and move to the easy then i went to the
kbs drama
of which i have nine of these which i
bought i bought a book in japan
and sometimes it helps me to read the
story in japanese so i get a better
sense of what it's all about if i'm a
bit confused as to who's saying what
stuff
uh but now these are a lot easier than
they were
even three months ago so so i noticed
you know even though i feel i'm getting
nowhere on my podcast it's forever not
understanding when i move to something a
little easier like the kbs drama series
i realize that actually i understand a
lot more than i used to but when they
speak i still have a lot of trouble
however
there is a rhythm to these dramas a
natural conversation type rhythm
which helps because you want to get in
the rhythm that's one of the big knocks
about
um you know texts that are written for
the learner or example sentences and so
forth we're never really confident
that's really how people speak whereas
if we get it in a conversation and
something that's engaging like that it
has more credibility it has more
resonance so it helps you get in the
language
but then after doing my kbs dramas i
went back to
this continuing korean which was one of
the first books i did in korean six
seven years ago recently found it on the
internet uploaded it to link went
through saving words and phrases in that
and of course that was a piece of cake
it was very easy and yet when i started
on it it was very very difficult so the
point is we do get better
and you have to trust in the process you
have to keep going all right and so
that's kind of my message for today
there were a few questions i could ask
there was one person
saying that college language courses are
not very effective and that link is
great i appreciate that from nikolai but
ultimately it's a matter of what you do
and
you have to take advantage of the
resources that are out there not just
your class resources but resources that
you can find on the internet including
link
and of course other resources that you
can study on their own or bring
interlink or whatever
uh another person said you know how do
you have the confidence to move on from
your current language and start a new
one
she speaks two languages besides english
i'm assuming it's a she because the
picture is a she
and want to learn korean but she's
afraid that she's not fluent enough in
the previous languages and wants to
reach perfection i've said it before
perfection is the enemy of the language
learner as i see it i regularly move on
when i don't understand the previous
lesson because we need repetition but we
need novelty and after a while if you're
just pounding on the same stuff you're
not learning very much anymore so move
ahead and there's lots of my languages
that i'm far from perfect in in fact
very dissatisfied with my level in and
still i go to new languages because i
have to make that choice am i going to
try to continue to improve knowing that
i'll never be satisfied in my level in a
given language or do i want to you know
discover a new language that's your
choice if you're motivated to go for
korean i would recommend you do so
and um
yeah as for the transcribed material
if you get on link
uh we'll see we can do it approach me on
the forum or on my
wallet link
um all right
do i plan to go to korea yes i would
love to go to korea
and all these people asking for
languages and efforts um
you know videos in different languages
including swedish
and uh chinese and cantonese and korean
and how did i learn swedish
and
yeah i one day we'll show you a list of
cds audio cds and reading material that
i have for swedish you just have to plow
through a lot of content
do i when i say that i've learned
japanese korean well enough to
understand the radio japanese yes korean
no and that's my big goal that's why i
want to get to or understand these
podcasts or other podcasts like them
that's what i'm working towards
uh
okay
yeah that's it for today so remember
believe in the process stay with the
process
lots of listening and reading you may
not think you're getting anywhere but
you are the brain
just a quick there was a some scientific
american published a paper pointing out
that chomsky's theory of universal
grammar was not
you know is not true that the evidence
doesn't support that yes the brain
learns patterns the brain adapts the
brain starts to create neural networks
which help it deal with the experience
that it has so you have to feed it the
language and it'll start to sort things
out of course you can help by reading
the odd bit of grammar and so forth but
stay with the process in time you'll get
there
a little bit of a long ramble today but
there you have it thank you bye